by the way before we get started your
your style your your impeccable taste in
in the way that you dress
especially i mean i will say backstage
you were a little you know
a little bit more relaxed but this is
great my trick is new shoes like new
shoes will make you feel
amazing those shoes are called creepers
which are like british shoes and i think
i bought them like the night before
uh so you know you new shoes you feel
good that's uh that's what that is i
picked them for two reasons number one
there's a rubber sole and number two
it's like an inch and a half so i just
get that in height
so that's what that is the height thing
was going really well i had a good set
it ended well and then conan came and
stood next to me and we looked like
something out of lord of the rings
uh half the comments from indian people
are like is he short
or is conan tall which one is it uh and
i'm like yeah
it's it's both actually it's both
a lot of work goes into a short late
night stand-up set join me
jp buck as i spotlight the comedians who
came up with some of my favorite coin
sets
this is the setup please welcome the
very funny
veer doss
[Music]
we didn't meet before you were booked
for the show that's the thing like
usually like i do meet somebody before
um but the first time that i saw you you
came to my attention uh a good friend of
mine haruko nabolu actually mentioned
uh you in a couple of times and said
like you have to see him you've got to
see veer
and i happen to be over in edinburgh i
think it's 2016
and we were performing and i had like a
nine o'clock show and yours was 11 45 at
night yeah
i remember i went back to my hotel room
to get like maybe 20 minutes of sleep
you you're at the gilded balloon yes in
the basement it felt like i was walking
into
um you know when you you think the band
like a band that's about to break
and you're getting to see them in the
cool venue before they go and play the
big arena
and you're like i was there the nice
thing about edinburgh is
there's there's not a lot of indians in
scotland and that's strange but
they just aren't um and so like you get
bollywood fans in edinburgh um and then
just guys who don't know who i
am right just random british people who
don't know who i am which is just the
two extremes of people you can have in
the audience
so it's just like man i love his movie
and i have no idea
uh and those two people interact with
each other and that's a nice sort of
palpable
energy when that happens and and these
were
these were preview shows because it was
just
i think it was like 45 people the entire
room was 45 or 50 people
in the basement late at night and it my
first time there
uh with that show so it was fun it was a
good time
and we didn't meet even then like even
then we didn't say hi or anything
i wanted to talk to you but you were
kind of
you were kind of getting swarmed after
the show
so i didn't i was like i could have
waited around but i didn't want to
bother you and i was like okay well
at some point i'm sure our pad will
cross flash forward
we didn't get to actually in person
until
i booked you for the show and you
actually came to the studio you and me
met
quickly like uh at the ice house and
passed yeah
i think right so so i got booked and i
knew that this was happening
and my manager reg was like all right
you need to get a set together you need
to get a set together and i'm like i
don't know
what that is because you know we're
indian and so for us like
you know six minutes means 15 minutes
you know
that's how we work what's cool about you
is you didn't even mention that you were
watching me at the ice house you just
kind of showed up
after the thing um and you were like i
like that
and and that was fun and and maybe go
here with it
but had i known you were in the audience
before i would have been a little more
nervous
you know so it was cool of you to kind
of wait until like uh
until i got done with that 10-minute
spot to give me notes on which which was
really nice it just so happened
and these bookings happen independently
and it depends on the schedule of the
guest
it depends on the schedule of like
sometimes people will will change their
dates last second so things get moved
around and
you can think that we purposely booked
two guests on the same show
yeah this did not happen and i don't
think i even realized it until like the
day of or day before
it was destiny man that was that was
insane you have a joke
in your set about the person who's the
lead guest
on the show i yeah i couldn't have
predicted it
in in a million years so yeah i had the
appoo from the simpsons joke
which was super important to me to do
because that's the one like
i used to have like the only two indians
that americans have really seen
are like gandhi and apu from the
simpsons right those are the two guys
which is why you don't consider are sexy
by the way like if there were more
so i did the apu from the simpsons joke
which i think was
this is there's no apu from the simpsons
joke coming up this is not that
and then i glance over and like hank
azaria's sitting right over there which
is insane
because he does the voice for apu uh and
i think that's
90 of your comment section is just
people going oh
snap like that's the entire comment
section on the thing
which is insane
uh my name is veer das i'm from bombay
in india has anybody ever been to india
well if you haven't been you must go
because your jobs have
i had seven other opening lines and
and this felt like what i would do if
this was a club
and so i ended up going with that i
remember like talking with my team about
it and a couple of friends and i'm like
you know it's possible that i lose them
at line one
you know because it's it's not hey good
to be here i'm so happy i'm from here
etc etc it's just
in straight um so
it either sets context for what the rest
of this is going to be
or i lose this crowd and never get on
american television again before i start
telling jokes i should clarify something
guys
i have an indian accent uh this is how i
talk
i'm not doing a bit there's no apu from
the simpsons joke coming up
but give me a little bit of time my
accent will grow on you right or just
give me like four or five generations
we'll be fine
and it's okay to not understand each
other there are things about me that you
may not understand like my accent
there are things about you america that
i don't understand like you're women
now here's the thing about this joke
what i love about this like it makes you
think that you're going to say something
almost like very judgmental about their
women and yes it's presented that way
but it's such a it's such a fun idea to
turn on the way that most comics would
deliver a joke like this
what i was nervous about in this point
is you know what's coming up
is uh you know you usually go have you
tried indian yet which is the line
coming up
right and what you want is
ladies going woo yeah you know or
whatever or
giving you a bit of a cat call you know
a little bit of an enthusiastic
thing which most places i played in
america americans are very enthusiastic
you guys are
a woo crowd i get the woo right
but the nightmare is is just you going
have you tried indian yet and ladies
going nuh-uh and
just silence um that's the nightmare
scenario but they were kind of
they were kind of nice about this i
don't understand american women i don't
understand how you can resist
this have you tried england
have you tried indian or you must
once you go brown the other colors let
you down
there are two mexicans in the back like
write this [ __ ] down man
this [ __ ] applies to us to say no i
apologize i don't mean to insult
mexicans i'm just a comedian i'm not
your president
once you go brown the other colors will
let you down is
now a tinder profile uh it's now
on t-shirts if you go through like
people dubbing my stuff on tick-tock
right from my movies and all of that
stuff
this is the number one line that they
dub
[Laughter]
this is the most memorable line from
that special as well and
i never thought it would happen you know
this was just one of those
it's an easy joke if i'm being
completely honest
uh but i i feel like
from this point on in the set we all
start to have a little fun
because you know now we now we know each
other
everybody's complaining too much you
have to work this out guys everybody's
like man we didn't choose this guy now
we got to live with him
we didn't vote for this guy now we got
to live with him to you americans that's
a president to most indians that's a
marriage
that's what donald trump is he's your
arranged marriage ladies and gentlemen
because in the most literal sense your
parents picked this guy out for you
you know arranged marriage works you
know
that's really where i'm coming from on
this joke is you got to work it out
it's an arranged marriage and this might
actually work out
let's be clear it didn't but you know it
might actually work out
but if you came out and you're like this
guy you know is blah blah blah and i
don't like him or
you know he's a fool etc etc i think
even somebody who didn't support him
politically i'd lose them
with this joke you know as
as you might you know as we might
respond to like an american coming over
and saying your prime minister
is you know something or the other so it
is a line that you kind of have to walk
because trump is an easy joke
like our prime minister is an easy joke
but
there's still that sentiment of yeah
it's [ __ ] but it's our [ __ ]
uh and i think you have to be cognizant
and kind of
respectful of that so you know if you
notice
the joke and i can only say this in
retrospect
because i wish it was all so pre-planned
i think what works for the joke in
retrospect and it was unplanned
is that there's something there's an
offering
of an idea that is indian towards the
situation that is american
you know uh but if it was just me going
i don't get it what are you doing
um i think there'd be a different
response
and there's religious phobia because i
believe that the world is changing and
religion can't keep
up i feel like we need to update every
major religion in the world
just take every religion and give it to
the company apple
every six months apple can update and
relaunch the religion to the world how
nice
would that be that's what we need we
need islam 6s ladies and gentlemen
we need jesus pro you would slow
terrorism down can you imagine how much
you would slow terrorism down
if every time some nut job wanted to
commit a jihad
you first had to sign a new online
agreement with apple
so first you have to get a jihad id then
you have to sync
all your boms and your devices to the
same jihad id
except that one bomb didn't work with
the old version of itunes and i have to
download the new version of itunes
and you're all set to go up to heaven
and get 72 virgins
but your icloud only holds six virgins
so now you have to upgrade
i think it's my defense mechanism as
well with a minute i do something that
is
slightly statementy and that's the only
word i have for it oh he made a
statement because i don't like that
you know i don't like sitting in that
for too long i like to go someplace
silly like really fast
and then come back um so i think this is
me doing that
from a dynamics point of view just let's
get silly for a bit my favorite part of
that joke is just android users going
what the hell is he
i'm always talking about the androids
look look how happy and confident i look
right and just just watch that
just look at that that swag pose and
then just watch it go away in like three
seconds
you're not alone i mean i even feel i
have to i
my neck cranes all the time when i'm
talking to him i think your camera guy
kind of went oh [ __ ] look at that
difference it
kind of went
[Laughter]
that's what it is it's great
[Music]
i don't think we've ever spoken about
this but one cool thing
that this did for me was bring back a
little bit of goodwill
uh and i'll tell you how um
i i think a year before this appearance
happened i just been in like a terrible
movie
like just a god-awful movie that was
panned by everybody and and it was kind
of
a box office disaster in bollywood right
and it was one of those movies where
the script was terrible and all of us
knew and we took the money you know
it was and just kind of got called out
by the media where they were like
you took the money man and now we're
going to destroy you you know
uh and and now go sit in exile for
for like five or six months um and so i
i just
i didn't have a movie until a year later
because i just finished shooting it so
it wouldn't come out until
you know well six months after this
appearance
and so the people's last memory of me
wasn't a great
memory is the best way i can put it um
and then this came out and you know the
media got behind it and people got
behind it and
and even people who were just critics
who
hated me you know uh were just kind of
doing articles going
fine his conan appearance was good okay
fine there i said
so so that happened so you guys got back
a little bit of
a goodwill for me in india as well